what's up everybody its Warren welcome
back to my channel today we have a lot
of exciting things to talk about as we
have a ton of new information about the
upcoming Loki series that is going to be
on Disney Plus including the first video
from the set of the Loki series
production released by Tom Hiddleston
himself and of course I'll be showing
that video in just a second along with
talking about who the main villain for
the Loki series could be how that main
villain has probably already been
revealed thanks to a casting call for
the show and to top it all off we've
learned a little bit more about the plot
of the Loki series that I'll be talking
about at the end of the video a ton to
dive into and breakdown today if you're
new be sure to subscribe with
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU and so you can interm I giveaway for
a chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 and
I'll talk more about the giveaway at the
end of the video so here's the video
that Tom Hiddleston released just
yesterday so of course as you just saw
it's a super short clip but nonetheless
very exciting because it's the first
thing that we've got about the Loki
series from its production and it was
released by Tom Hiddleston himself he
posted this on Instagram with the title
prep is going really well
hashtag Loki now whatever he's doing
whatever film he's prepping for he
obviously didn't stick to landing that's
what prep is for and the awesome part is
that now that filming has begun for the
series much like the one division series
the Falcon and the Winter Soldier series
and of course the Eternals we get leaked
photos and videos so expect more photos
and videos that are of course going to
be leaked to come out very soon that
will reveal more about the plot of the
Loki series but of course as we all know
it doesn't necessarily take a leaked
photo or a video to figure out more
about the plot recently the Loki series
has had some casting calls which
revealed two major things about the Loki
series one is that even though season 1
is a long way away season 2 has been
confirmed and 2 the main villain of the
series might possibly have been revealed
there's been a report by Charles Murphy
from Murphy's multiverse com stating
that some of the contracts for the
actors that are signed on for the Loki
series have an option for season
- and he said on his website and I quote
him here I can confirm with 100%
certainty that a second season of Loki
will happen so even though we don't have
season 1 yet great news for Loki fans
we're going to be getting a season 2 but
this is pretty much expected for all of
the Disney Plus series that are going to
be coming to phase 4 and phase 5 we can
expect to have multiple seasons of all
of the shows that are going to be coming
because remember all of the Marvel
Disney Plus shows do take place in the
MCU everything that happens in these
shows affects the movies that we're
going to see in the MCU as well and
Kevin Feige has already stated that
we're going to see some of the
characters in these shows in actual
movies so definitely expect multiple
seasons of each show but then there's
the reveal of what looks to be the main
villain a recent casting call for the
Loki series says that they're looking
for a female who portrays Caucasian
between five six and five eight with
blond hair and they emphasize blond hair
now if you look throughout Marvel comics
history that involves Thor and Loki
there aren't too many females that have
blond hair at least none that are of any
significant importance to the Thor and
Loki storyline that fans would be
excited to see in fact there really is
only one character that comes to mind
and she really is perfect to be
introduced in the series and that person
is enchantress for the avid comic book
reader you probably know all about
enchantress but for those of you who
don't know let me explain who she is and
why she's perfect to be introduced in
the Loki series and then go on to be in
Thor love and thunder
you see enchantress is one of Thor's
greatest enemies in the comics and there
are actually two versions of her both of
which tie into Thor and Loki the first
enchantress goes by the name of amaura
she's Anna's Guardian and as one of the
most powerful sorcerers ever much like
Loki himself now of course we already
know that the Loki series is going to
tie into Thor love and thunder and in
Thor love and thunder we know that Jane
Foster is going to be able to lift and
wield Mjolnir and become Thor and this
is really important to know because in
the comics enchantress actually has a
connection to Jane Foster now in the
comics much like in the MCU Odin doesn't
really approve of Thor and Jane Foster
he sees Jane Foster as a distraction for
Thor so in the comics he sends
enchantress and
the execution are to eliminate her
scourge ends up trapping Jane Foster in
another dimension but of course Thor
comes and rescues her enchantress kind
of goes rogue on the mission as well and
Thor brings the two of them scourge and
enchantress back to Asgard there Odin
then banishes the two of them to earth
and once they're on earth they join
baron zemo's masters of evil now this is
pretty important to know MCU wise
because this could connect the Loki
series to the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series we know that Zemo is
going to be returning for the show and
it's been highly rumored and speculated
that Zemo is going to be a part of the
Thunderbolts and it could even be the
start of him assembling his masters of
evil which enchantress could be a part
of
now enchantress also has a pretty deep
connection to the Avengers of well
despite her basically being in love with
Thor she's attacked Thor and the
Avengers many times one time she even
hypnotized Thor into attacking the other
Avengers she did this with spells on a
special brew making him believe that
they are enemies of humanity but luckily
for Thor Iron Man snapped him back in
the shape but as you can kind of see
enchantress is basically a female
version of Loki and the two of them
actually get along very well in the
comics now there is actually a second
version of enchantress called Sylvie
Rushton and she's actually created and
given mystic powers by Loki Loki created
her as a tool for chaos which of course
Loki loves and just like Loki is a
trickster enchantress isn't too far off
she seduces people with her looks and
her charm and mine controls them again
basically a female version of Loki and
could even be his love interest in the
show that's something that we haven't
seen Loki have yet a love interest and
since this is going to be a show all
about Loki it may be possible and this
also aligns with a recent plot leak that
we got for the Loki series and
considering the fact that production has
begun for the Loki series we just got
our first video this could indeed be
real so if you are trying to avoid all
and any possible spoilers for the Loki
series you should click away now now if
you're still with me we actually know
quite a bit about the plot of the Loki
series we know that it's going to take
place immediately following the events
of Avengers endgame when the Avengers go
back in 2012 and Loki escapes with the
tesseract it's going to pick up right
after Loki escaped and we even have a
logline that states the Loki series
follows Loki after the events of
Avengers endgame as the trickster uses
the powers of the tesseract to travel
throughout human history and change
historical events so Loki is going to be
travelling all throughout time in this
new alternate universe that he created
by escaping with the tesseract and
according to fandom wire.com they say
that Loki will jump through the
multiverse with the aid of the tesseract
and returned to the current MCU timeline
/ dimension just in time for Thor love
and thunder it's also stated that Loki
is going to bring back meal near into
the main timeline for Thor love and
thunder now this means that somewhere
along the line of the Loki series Loki
is going to have a serious change of
heart because the Loki that we saw in
2012 it definitely is not worthy enough
to lift me own ear that means sometime
during the series he's going to become
worthy enough to lift me on air because
he's going to bring it back to the main
timeline in Thor love and thunder but
why would luck he bring back Munir to
the main timeline to give to Thor well
and chant risqué the reason enchantress
could threaten Asgard after all she's
done that many times in the comics
before and a recent plot leaked if true
gives us a little bit more insight and
this plot leaks says that rumor has it
that the series will actually follow the
dead Loki narrating his trajectory much
of the story will be the younger version
of Loki which means that Tom Hiddleston
will not be the only actor to play the
character in addition Frigga will have a
role in the series the younger version
of Thor will also appear scenes with
Odin will not show the face of actor
Anthony Hopkins Loki will narrate the
tragic trajectory for the nornes trying
to save his soul from hell and then it
says that karnilla will be a villain of
the series
now karnilla is very important one
because she is Queen of the Norns and
two she trained and taught enchantress
enchantress was car nillas apprentice so
it seems like this is all sort of coming
together for the Loki series because
remember that Loki is going to tie into
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness and it appears that Loki is
going to be jumping through different
multiverses as well therefore he could
encounter two different versions or even
more of enchantress one could be his
love interest but another could threaten
him and threaten Asgard and clearly at
some point in time he's going to have a
chain
of heart since he's going to bring me
linear back to the main timeline to give
to Thor which of course we know
eventually Jane Foster is going to wield
and that is supposedly how the Loki
series is going to tie into Thor love
and thunder
now this casting call for enchantress
actually lines up with a recent rumor
that Jennifer Lawrence is being eyed to
play in centrist now this is just a
rumor it hasn't been confirmed by any
means but it does line up with this
casting call for enchantress so a lot of
big news for the Loki series production
has officially begun and it seems like
we're going to be getting a season two
which is great news because no doubt
that this series is going to be
absolutely fantastic and it appears that
enchantress has been revealed to be at
least one of the villains of the Loki
series and possibly even a love interest
as well and it definitely looks like
there's going to be multiple versions of
Loki throughout the show which makes
sense considering the fact that it's
going to tie into the multiverse so let
me know what you think about this let me
know what you think about enchantress
being the main villain or a possible
love interest for Loki let me know in
the comments down below also don't
forget to give the video a like and
subscribe when notifications turned on
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the Loki series and the MCU
all you have to do to enter my xbox one
and ps4 giveaway is subscribe when
notifications turned on like the video
and leave a comment down below and I'm
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers all the
details are in the description down
below don't forget to follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
fluff